citizens of the reject nation greg here john good
morning to you good morning how are you i am so
excited right now ladies and gentlemen i saw my
favorite band perform live last night so i got
12 hours of sleep to get up here half hour six in
the morning to do this and it's gonna be worth it
cause that teaser trick i feel like people
are sleeping on andor when that teaser looks
awesome that's already been greenlit for a season
two meaning they have a lot of faith in this
leave a like use the force to leave a like
it doesn't take much force so do it anyhoo
let's see what's going on in this trailer
beautiful already beautiful
to steal from the empire so eerie you just walk in
like you belong they're so proud of themselves so
fat and satisfied they can't imagine not someone
like me who would ever get inside their house
cassian the empire is choking us so
slowly we're starting not to notice
what i'm asking is this wouldn't you
rather give it all to something real
damn this looks so beautiful yeah i need all
the heroes i can get he's the header figure
for the greater good oh [__] call
it what you will saw let's call it
there's fermenting out there
some pockets of fermenting
you're in my neck
are you a fish or are you a thief
you're slipping i'm not sleeping i've
just been hiding for too long oh [__]
well as long as everyone thinks i'm an irritation
there's a good chance they'll miss what i'm really
doing what are you really doing playing both sides
helping the rebellion evolution looks like we'll
be televised i'm tired of losing a disney fuss
three episode premiere is it september 21st that
was august yeah i thought it was the end of august
and i thought it was a two episode from here that
must be really enthused about this man i heard
there's like 12 episodes in this i guess we missed
some updates here yeah that's some big stuff yeah
i mean the main talk of this trailer lately has
been like how beautiful it looks and yeah it does
look beautiful looks like a combination of actual
on-set location shots and then a combination
combined with they have to be using that volume
technology as which has become so synonymous with
making these now especially when the mandalorian
came out there's something about it that just
feels so tangible and feels so real and i really
like that we're going to be getting like a lot of
at least the trailer seems like we're going to be
getting a lot of mon mothma at the the early days
you know you see you're talking with the coruscant
senate council and that she's placating to the
empire so it seems right right but she's actually
slowly helping the rebellion out but one part that
struck me is rather interesting i think the
character what is this selling skarsgard's
character i think it's lutheran there's that
moment between him and mon mothma they're
exchanging what looks like pleasantries hey i
don't know much about this show but i'm like wait
are are they working like together by this point
in the show they both look like they're living the
luxurious you know political uh empire lifestyle
yeah but then when the way they greeted each other
it's kind of seemed like oh i don't know if they
know that they really want to take down the empire
so don't think that i'm just
actually resting on my laurels
showing the empire life i really do want to resist
a cover to maintain because like yeah diego luna
looks awesome in this show i really liked him
in rogue one and i really i i really like rogue
one i know rogue one kind of gets crapped on
for that but i think rogue one's great because
yeah as gorgeous as this looks and as i love that
music in here what eerie ticking time clock music
just feels like there's something percolating
under the surface that's just gonna come to
the rise and i like that it's like this
ghostly haunting like i don't know how
they are haunted by a lot of the the traumas
that the empire has inflicted on them especially
a character like cassian andor and everything
he lost as a kid and has grown up into this now
he's described it as like a refugee story you're
watching him find his place in this rebellion
and look for hope in the darkest of times like
this is like top-tier empire work right here
you know um this is when their full formation
and at their strongest this definitely looks
like a star war and it's funny because you know
hearing people ponder and contemplate the current
state of star wars what star wars should become
and where it should go feeling like an actual
war is taking place with real fallout you know
like wars displace people and yeah diego luna
has described this as a refugee story and that
really feels tangible from this trailer it's like
yeah you have these characters who are in these
more privileged positions you know doing their
double agent duty in such a way but you're also
looking at the people who are bearing the biggest
brunt of an intergalactic conflict like this and
so i love the way that they infuse perspective
into a lot of the shots they're going for and it
looks like they're even further going down that
rabbit hole of making everything look like it is
some kind of sci-fi illustration uh but also using
that not only to go to make you go wow beautiful
but to make you go oh wow this is really harsh and
harrowing injecting a certain level of kind of
grit immediacy into the star wars formula while
maintaining all those aesthetics with so many
different characters to focus on in this world
so many different spin-offs and things i really
like the tone we're getting here and and while
it is like kind of a meme of current uh you know
franchise ips and what not having like a dark and
gritty franchise or something that has comments
about you know war and the fallout from that i
don't know this seems like a very appropriate
place for that and i'm excited to hopefully
get some new life in terms of the characters that
we're seeing i always hope that one of these shows
they ride so much on the things we know already
and this seems like a cool opportunity to do some
of that but also expound and uh yeah show us a
different glimpse into you know this intergalactic
conflict yeah and and and stellen skarsgard
definitely dies uh what'd you guys think about
the andor trailer i'm excited for it it looks
great refreshing different paintless cinematic hey
michael linden you've been with us for so long
you have shown commitment loyalty love pledge
your duty to the empire of the reject nation and
i trust you with everything we we have to offer
i just don't know as many people as loyal as
you so thank you for being a loyalist occultist
a zealot everything about washington that we
love about a follower of the reject nation you
take care of all of europe for us and make sure
all of our shipments and goods get transported
properly and are delivered to the right
people and don't forget to collect the tax
yes on the local townsfolk protect our
exports our spice trade you found the
star wars reference thank you no problem i
was searching this whole time patron dash